was the president right there briefing
the american people from the
white house podium on the corona virus
saying that things are going to get
worse before they get better striking a
much more serious and measured tone
about the virus talking about some of
the successes that the
administration has had 50 million tests
done
the mortality rate in hospital stays
being slashed in half
since april national guard medical
personnel surging
into the southwest because it does look
like the sun belt
may be looking at becoming a hot spot
and the president's saying we've learned
a lot
in the last few months about this virus
that are much more
and better prepared to take on whether
it's a second wave or
an emergence in certain different areas
of the country
the governors have everything they need
the president said
and warned people to avoid packed bars
and said wear masks but said there will
be
no more shutdowns and we are in
advanced stages of vaccine testing let's
take it around the table greg gudfield
what did you think
about the president spoke for i think it
was just maybe 20 to 25 minutes there
i thought it would you know he reigned
in the impromptu
in improvisational elements of his
delivery
so what you got was a very straight
summary which then it becomes shorter
because there's not there's not a lot of
the side commentary
so i i really don't know what cnn's
excuse is for not
showing it because when you have someone
go out there and it's delivering news to
a an american nation that needs it
it seems like i mean imagine if you're
watching cnn right now
of course you can't but imagine if you
did you wouldn't have you wouldn't know
this happened
yeah it looks like they dialed it in all
the questions
were asked but they didn't take the top
where he delivered all of the factual
information
to the american people degan what did
you think about the president's
presentation on
substance and style well he's owning it
and he's leading he was up there by
himself with
no one else speaking about what he the
white house
and the nation are doing to fight this
virus so he is taking
ownership of the future and the road
ahead
and to he was asked about the economy i
will point out that
because of the shutdowns the country
lost more than 22 million jobs in a
matter of months
it's regained seven and a half million
of those that's about 34
of the jobs have returned and what is
and
and what are they going to be doing in
the months ahead well there's another at
least trillion dollar aid package
that's 600 extra per week per week
extra per week that people have been
getting in unemployment benefits
that has been a lifeline for many
individuals and he talked about
extending that it might be at a lower
rate at a lower amount maybe sunset
in the coming weeks but that's not
something despite pushback
from some conservatives that's not
something that is going away
and that's going to give the economy a
lift as we fight through this virus
uh yes juan the president clearly right
at the top
framing it as a chinese virus and then
multiple times
during the presentation talking about
how this emerged from china how china
failed to stop
it and let people from wuhan fly all
over the world
definitely a different position than the
president had taken earlier
during the pandemic
i think he's always been anxious to
blame china he didn't initially well i
think
that was partly because he was involved
in trying to get that trade deal done
jesse but
uh subsequent to that he has been quick
to blame china to bring fouchy to blame
obama i don't know who he hasn't been
but
i i think that uh what stands out to me
here
is the change in tone that we've all
discussed so far
and what strikes me on that point is
that this is a
president who was very slow to come
around on the seriousness of the
pandemic
and very slow therefore to engage things
like the mask and still
his administration is talking about
cutting funding for
testing cutting funding for tracing uh
that that's very concerning and also i
would point out he says you know 99
of these cases are in adults as if oh
just reopen the schools when in fact
if the kids go home to mom dad to
grandparents to neighbors
they could spread the disease to people
who are in fact quite vulnerable
but it's what strikes me is the question
of his credibility speaking to the
american people
before he went on you jesse emily
everybody said
we hope he's more substantive and more
direct in terms of delivering data
and i think it's at least a mix that
he's defensive
uh and he's lowered the the bar of kind
of sprinkling magic dust that's going to
disappear magically we're going to open
everything by easter clearly that's gone
but he's still a very defensive man on
this issue i didn't see him as defensive
i thought he was pretty honest and
forthright emily
what was your interpretation of today
that's exactly right jesse i thought it
was excellent it was clear
competent data driven and juan pointed
out it seemed to be a shift but i will
just note that the one of the final
reporters at the end
that was sort of his question he said mr
president um we seem to have sort of a
shift
in your approach here um and i just
thought that was excellent
but to your question to me jesse your
second one at the top of the hour
when it doesn't matter that it's all
about shaping because remember what the
first question was from a reporter out
of the gate was
so mr president we hear that you're
getting multiple tests a day
there was no question on all of the
facts and figures that the president
presented in the beginning of the hour
that was positive and the biggest debate
of all
the biggest line of questioning was the
mask debate why don't you wear one and
whatever
no matter what you put in front of these
people there's always going to be
a different shiny object that they're
following and respectfully one to your
point
um that it's never going to be enough if
he sat there running out with his hair
on fire
oh my gosh this is the worst and most
horrible thing that still wouldn't be
enough
even if the economy collapsed but i
thought right now it was excellent
i think that was a good point and um
every single question was framed as
the president and the election and how
it plays politically not on the
substance of the war on
the coronavirus